When a movement includes in its discourse
language around gender equality,
it increases dramatically the chances it will adopt nonviolence,
and thus, the likelihood it will succeed.
The research squared up with my own documentation
of political organizing in Israel and Palestine.
I've noticed that movements which welcome women into leadership positions,
such as the one I documented in a village called Budrus,
were much more likely to achieve their goals.
This village was under a real threat of being wiped off the map
when Israel started building the separation barrier.
The proposed route would require
the destruction of this community's olive groves, their cemeteries
and would ultimately enclose the village from all sides.
Through inspired local leadership,
they launched a nonviolent resistance campaign to stop that from happening.
The odds were massively stacked against them.
But they had a secret weapon:
a 15-year-old girl
who courageously jumped in front of a bulldozer
which was about to uproot an olive tree, stopping it.
In that moment, the community of Budrus realized what was possible
if they welcomed and encouraged women to participate in public life.
And so it was that the women of Budrus went to the front lines day after day,
using their creativity and acumen to overcome multiple obstacles they faced
in a 10-month unarmed struggle.
And as you can probably tell at this point,
they win at the end.
The separation barrier was changed completely
to the internationally recognized green line,
and the women of Budrus came to be known across the West Bank
for their indomitable energy.
(Applause)
Thank you.
I want to pause for a second, which you helped me do,
because I do want to tackle two very serious misunderstandings
that could happen at this point.
The first one is that I don't believe
women are inherently or essentially more peaceful than men.
But I do believe that in today's world,
women experience power differently.
Having had to navigate being in the less powerful position
in multiple aspects of their lives,
women are often more adept
at how to surreptitiously pressure for change
against large, powerful actors.
The term "manipulative," often charged against women in a derogatory way,
reflects a reality in which women have often had to find ways
other than direct confrontation to achieve their goals.
And finding alternatives to direct confrontation
is at the core of nonviolent resistance.
Now to the second potential misunderstanding.
I've been talking a lot about my experiences in the Middle East,
and some of you might be thinking now
that the solution then is for us to educate Muslim and Arab societies
to be more inclusive of their women.
If we were to do that, they would be more successful.
They do not need this kind of help.
Women have been part of the most influential movements
coming out of the Middle East,
but they tend to be invisible to the international community.
Our cameras are largely focused on the men
who often end up involved in the more confrontational scenes
that we find so irresistible in our news cycle.
And we end up with a narrative that not only erases women
from the struggles in the region
but often misrepresents the struggles themselves.
In the late 1980s, an uprising started in Gaza,
and quickly spread to the West Bank and East Jerusalem.
It came to be known as the First Intifada,
and people who have any visual memory of it
generally conjure up something like this:
Palestinian men throwing rocks at Israeli tanks.
The news coverage at the time
made it seem like stones, Molotov cocktails and burning tires
were the only activities taking place in the Intifada.
This period, though, was also marked by widespread nonviolent organizing
in the forms of strikes, sit-ins and the creation of parallel institutions.
During the First Intifada,
whole sectors of the Palestinian civilian population mobilized,
cutting across generations, factions and class lines.
They did this through networks of popular committees,
and their use of direct action and communal self-help projects
challenged Israel's very ability
to continue ruling the West Bank and Gaza.
According to the Israeli Army itself,
97 percent of activities during the First Intifada were unarmed.
And here's another thing that is not part of our narrative about that time.
For 18 months in the Intifada,
women were the ones calling the shots behind the scenes:
Palestinian women from all walks of life
in charge of mobilizing hundreds of thousands of people
in a concerted effort to withdraw consent from the occupation.
Naela Ayesh, who strived to build a self-sufficient Palestinian economy
by encouraging women in Gaza to grow vegetables in their backyards,
an activity deemed illegal by the Israeli authorities at that time;
Rabeha Diab, who took over decision-making authority
for the entire uprising
when the men who had been running it
were deported;
Fatima Al Jaafari, who swallowed leaflets containing the uprising's directives
in order to spread them across the territories
without getting caught;
and Zahira Kamal,
who ensured the longevity of the uprising
by leading an organization
that went from 25 women to 3,000 in a single year.
Despite their extraordinary achievements,
none of these women have made it into our narrative of the First Intifada.
We do this in other parts of the globe, too.
In our history books, for instance, and in our collective consciousness,
men are the public faces and spokespersons
for the 1960s struggle for racial justice in the United States.
But women were also a critical driving force,
mobilizing, organizing, taking to the streets.
How many of us think of Septima Clark
when we think of the United States Civil Rights era?
Remarkably few.
But she played a crucial role in every phase of the struggle,
particularly by emphasizing literacy and education.
She's been omitted, ignored,
like so many other women who played critical roles
in the United States Civil Rights Movement.
This is not about getting credit.
It's more profound than that.
The stories we tell matter deeply to how we see ourselves,
and to how we believe movements are run
and how movements are won.
The stories we tell about a movement like the First Intifada
or the United States Civil Rights era
matter deeply and have a critical influence
in the choices Palestinians,
Americans
and people around the world will make
next time they encounter an injustice
and develop the courage to confront it.
If we do not lift up the women who played critical roles in these struggles,
we fail to offer up role models to future generations.
Without role models, it becomes harder
for women to take up their rightful space
in public life.
And as we saw earlier,
one of the most critical variables
in determining whether a movement will be successful or not
is a movement's ideology regarding the role of women
in public life.
This is a question of whether we're moving
towards more democratic and peaceful societies.
In a world where so much change is happening,
and where change is bound to continue at an increasingly faster pace,
it is not a question of whether we will face conflict,
but rather a question
of which stories will shape
how we choose to wage conflict.
Thank you.
(Applause)